have you noticed James that Disobedience
has been on the rise within corporations
and uh 100% it's in the last month so I
mean the whistleblowing involves a
crisis of conscience they have to weigh
their loyalty to the organization versus
to the public interest and and and I
think that you know with the story that
we're we're going to talk about here
tonight with these airline pilots
actually St Clair did you see that video
this week yeah it was just like an
explosion it's it's just everything's
sort of been festering and getting to
this point and just blew open like this
little C of Pilots I did a spaces with
her and I would say about 70% of airline
pilots are more conservative and about
80 to 90% of the ticket agents are more
liberal so you know these PE these
people inside the airlines you know they
they're they're they're begging me to do
something about it you know expose these
buses are dropping people off so it's
remarkable it's a remarkable scene